this episode of the gist is brought to
you by Castlevania two lords of Shadow
this month has brought us the
masterpiece in videogame naming called
the lego movie videogame which naturally
made me wonder if there's ever been a
game that has a worse name than this one
actually there are a whole bunch for
every elegantly titled mass effect or
dragon age there are so many game names
that are straight-up tortola just
completely nonsensical or just plain
suck this one is kind of sneaky because
on a first listen it doesn't sound so
bad and it's attached to a game it's
pretty great so Moses forgave Larian
studios for divine divinity but those
days are over the title oped me in the
same way that beyond the beyond did you
don't need to move past the beyond
because I get it you're already beyond
it's the same deal with divine divinity
we sort of had the divine part covered
in the first word it didn't really need
to be clarified with a noun of exactly
the same root word the divinity in
question was never going to be anything
other than divine and if it was
something else like the tainted divinity
or the divinity closely resembling
Christmas cake then that's when a
clarifying adjective would have come in
handy your game name is bad and you
should feel bad fortunately they did
decide to entitle the sequel ego
draconis which translates to I of the
Dragons much much cooler I don't want to
alarm anybody but we as a gaming
community seem to have fallen into a
disturbing trend of accepting son
popular game titles as viable when they
don't actually make any sense when you
think about them in the realm of madness
that is Metal Gear Solid we have
resident evil now resident evil sounds
totally fine when you say it once or
even twice but when you actually sit
there and think about it it sure isn't a
name that stands up to the strength of
the series to be fair resident evil with
the American version of the original
games title which was in English
biohazard I personally think biohazard
is a great and sensible name whereas
Resident Evil sort of conjures up the
image of the embodiment of evil
squatting in a derelict Department and
generally being an [ __ ] to his Co
habitus do let me know if you think
resident evil is a poor title or if
there's some grand metaphor that I'm
missing the next game name all my list
isn't even silly it just makes literally
no sense no matter which way you spin it
I'm talking Square Enix's infinite
undiscovery yep that's infinite
undiscovery I should take a moment to
mention that a lot of these titles
originate from Japan so I can't tell you
how well they stand up in their country
of origin but luckily for us it makes
them no less hilarious here my number
one problem with infinite undiscovery is
that undiscovery is not a word it seems
like it would be the lack of any
discovery but if that's the case how do
you do that infinitely unless the game
is in fact empty of achievements and
filled with pissing about where the main
characters achieve nothing beyond what
they did at the start of the game if
that's how it goes down I'm a hundred
percent on board and I retract this
edition at least infinite discovery
would have implied constant adventure or
conversely finite undiscovery implies a
period of pissing about before they get
into that hole enticing discovery part
is this the most convoluted tale ever
well that's your call but I think the
next choice on my list is probably a
pretty fierce competitor another
Japanese title brought us the Majesty
that is bravely default another game
name it seems totally valid until you
think about it too long because it
consists of two adjectives the full name
of the JRPG and spiritual successor to
Final Fantasy is bravely default flying
fairy and the entire thing reads like
someone picked four words out of a hat
threw them in an order that made vague
sense and went along with the important
work of game development it starts out
with an adverb which is an ER know in
long works of fiction let alone Curt
video game titles and sort of turns the
word default into a noun so really it
should be the main subject of the title
but unfortunately in this case default
is in its definition a word the
completely lack substance or intriguing
bias it's just default I suppose at
least it's brave lady
where there's a nonsense and confusion
there's also the exact opposite absolute
clarity and perfect explanation although
funnily enough that doesn't make for a
better game title as indicated by my
final example hello I'm Fred Couples
welcome to Golf Magazine's 36 great
holes golf magazine presents 36 great
hole starring Fred Couples doesn't leave
a lot to the imagination in fact it
leaves nothing to the imagination you're
told right there that a golfing magazine
is sponsoring the game you'll be
knocking into 36 holes which are
apparently great and you'll get to fill
the shoes of the incomparable Fred
Couples this is the kind of title that
makes you wish for more bravely default
sand on turnitin discoveries or whatever
if we follow Golf Magazine's example we
may as well be calling Dark Souls yell
at your TV for a bit and then go make
sandwich all the sims achieve the
American dream in seven and a half in
game days if I've got my choice i'll
take my divine divinity to go but you
should let me know what your favorite
all-time terrible game titles are or if
you think there's a massive contender
i've forgotten i'll be back next week
but unlike these awful Caymans be sure
to leave me your sensibly phrase and
well worded comments
you